how are you guys doing hi
i'm doing excellent um uh you guys are
in a hotel i wasn't expecting you guys
to actually be together
oh i know i we're fully tested we are
we're tested and we've done all the
things
uh it must be nice to see other people
anyway i'm i'm it is although i have to
say i was in australia for many months
during covert so i was spoiled it was
fully open
until it wasn't
yeah
which is clearly the case with this
um yeah
i was gonna say because i have extra
time with you guys i like throwing some
curve balls at the beginning um for each
of you
these i swear these are painless um what
tv series would you love to guest star
on
oh
um
oh
westworld
is it current does it have to be running
no you can go vintage if you want
i i want to pop up in
in the sopranos no
the wire the wire
they're both very good choices um what
movie or movies do you think you've seen
the most
the greatest showman
i'm not joking
i'm not if i'm just gonna be honest i'm
being serious i love that movie so much
i cry at the end every time
i love it to pieces yeah but let me give
you a different answer probably
hitchcock's rope no
i'm not over that
i love the great don't try to sound cool
now by saying hitchcock
i'm being i'm owning it i love the great
show that's probably embarrassing dude
jackman's just still a dream but he is a
dream he is yeah
um
gosh this is really throwing me for one
i'm sorry i'm talking about your time um
five minutes okay uh what about what i
don't know i can talk about a great show
for a bit keep going yeah
we're worried about it one movie right
now this is insane
um okay it's everything you're in the
mood for nothing you
in the mood for love
oh that's quite good yes yeah um i'm i'm
very curious if ben can actually sing
any of the greatest showmen is that not
happening it's not me well i can i can i
can you know in my shower
yeah
no i mean listen there's there are some
very very uh catchy songs in that movie
i'm being sincere about the catchy songs
nobody catchy songs man despite the fact
that he goes you know he thinks i'm not
going to carry on with this
oh my god he thinks he thinks he needs
the love of the world that she just
means a lot of a few good people i think
that's a very very uh wonderful
i i literally and this is not a joke i i
literally interviewed hugh last week for
a very long time i did not bring up
greatest showman but i think listen he's
what we call a talented actor
yeah and probably the nicest human
on the planet maybe i literally oh
uh him and keanu are both but we're
getting into a sidewalk let's let's
jumping into why i got to talk to you
guys today um what was it about this
i see a lot of movies and this is a
movie that has a few twists and turns
that i was not expecting i would imagine
for both of you reading the script you
must have been like wait what as you're
flipping the pages can you sort of talk
about that
i think that's why we chose to do it it
was
as we read a lot of scripts and it was a
genre that i haven't read a lot of it's
definitely having a little
oh my god i did not recognize you say hi
hi how are you oh my god
who's running towards me
i can tell that was justice
yeah it was indeed yeah oh
anyway um
what's up
dramatic
please
uh yeah i think we're just both
surprised by like the twists and turns
in the script and we read so many
scripts as actors you know some shorts
people doing this business and it just
completely blew us away they were just
completely blindsided and um i think we
both thought it was just something we
want to be a part of i mean i i get the
feeling you're a cinephile did you see
the twists and turns coming i did not uh
i was yeah i was i was like what i think
it's like an hour into the movie and i'm
like wait what and then as things keep
going i'm like i i actually my
girlfriend could hear me in the other
room when i said what
like i had that kind of reaction because
i was watching it on you know my
computer i just i was very surprised
just what i was saying great great
have you guys been happy
by the way if you yeah i don't want to
get into spoilers but that's hard to
yeah ben i am curious though so was it
in the script that you were going to
basically be shirtless entire film was
when you got to set that you found out
that you're just not going to be wearing
a shirt uh
actually actually
he was supposed to wear a shirt the
entire time but i insisted i'm only
doing the film if i'm naked for 95 no
i no i think it was
it was in the script yeah it was in the
script yeah there was
it was important that seb seemed like
um
something which justice his character
thomas wasn't the
thomas would have that kind of jealousy
perhaps or not necessary jealousy but
just just an understanding that this guy
works out and and you know this guy
is
you know at least i'm not we're talking
about myself you know but that he's you
know he's um
desirable in some kind of way which
maybe thomas isn't uh and that's also to
do with with character and attitude as
well as very kind of
he's kind of very alpha you know he's
very alpha male very kind of um
uh
demanding but in a very kind of
dominating way which you know
they just they just pull the opposite so
it's the contrast there no 100
but yeah yeah
one of the other things that's
interesting is that there's scenes where
you're being obviously photographed from
essentially across the street which is
so there's no cameras where you guys are
which allows you i would imagine a lot
of flexibility in how you're going to
move about the scene because you don't
really
it's it's you know there's you don't
have to not the continuity if you will
but can you sort of talk about filming
those scenes where you're being
photographed from across the street and
what that is sort of maybe that's more
liberating for allowing you the freedom
to do things
exactly we've been talking about how it
felt very unique to film in that way our
experience as actors and i found it
liberating i think you found it more
annoying than i did but
i found it very liberating um just
because the camera was
far away enough that i felt a little
more free with not hitting certain marks
um but we did have anti-marks
where you couldn't stand in certain
positions because
you you'll be behind some window pane or
something so we had to avoid certain
mask marks but i don't know i felt
i liked it it was like putting on a play
tash liked it i i
i didn't love it i think i found it i
think the camera adds a certain level of
energy and i feel like you know it but
there's both sides of the argument and
sometimes i did feel that way and then
there was other times i just felt like
when the camera's not there you know
when it's when you're there and the
camera's in the room and it's rolling
and it's about to go you can always feel
like well i can't you know feel myself
filling up ready to emote and go and do
that and there's that energy and it's
alive and i felt i found it quite hard
to generate that knowing it was all the
way across the other side of the world
and we were being directed through a um
you know tannoy system but not mike's
fault michael michael mohan that is you
know and he would come around
and give us notes all the time i mean
that guy covered more steps than anyone
at that point running between the two
apartments yeah um can't speak highly
enough of mike but um
yeah
it's interesting uh so you guys you know
this is an erotic thriller and it's it's
interesting because for me hollywood
will let you basically do
horrible things to people
violence wise and the mpaa is totally
cool with it but if you show a little
bit of sex or basically there seems to
be a
roadblock up if
i don't know it seems to be like
hollywood's gotten more prude as the
decades have gone on can you sort of
talk about or if you don't mind talking
about the fact that um i guess just you
guys made it in any aspect of what i
just talked about i didn't ask a good
question at all
i know i don't even know what you mean
it was a very good question i think
i don't know i used to be honest i'm
going to be honest i really thought
about it that much until today why
haven't we had that kind of 90s
psychosexual thriller um
for about what feels like 10 years i
don't know
maybe longer i forget how old i am but
um partly things when i look back at
those a lot of those movies they're very
much they're great movies but they're of
their time and um and often they like
is the one i think of you know glenn
close's character
is
ostensibly just kind of crazy you know
and i feel it doesn't really explore her
exactly why she is this person that's
come into this uh into this man's life
and it feels like he's very much through
the
um through a man's lens you know so i
think um maybe it's the period of time
has been necessary to kind of maybe
evolve that genre and make it something
i mean i love that movie by the way but
it's just of its time you know but
evolve that genre and make it more
current to today and kind of explore
every character within the script and
also in this one we have a female
protagonist which i think is a flip on
the genre as well
i don't know why there is a blind eye
for violence um when it comes to ratings
and
censorship it does feel like there is
some sort of imbalance with that um
agreed i don't know
yeah it's just something i you know it
doesn't make sense to me um yeah
i love learning about the behind the
scenes with the making of a film for
each of you what do you think maybe
would surprise people to learn about the
making of this movie
but it was made in uh entirely in a
studio more or less there was some
experience but it was the apartments
were actually built inside a studio so
what was amazing for us as as actors was
the fact that it felt like we had our
own little apartments and so they really
did they really did so all the shots you
know shot from across the way looking in
on our lives are that's really the way
it was happening essentially maybe the
walls are cardboard or instead of stone
you know but um it was very real and
canadian winter was just freezing
outside so we had this little box every
day that we'd just come to work and be
in our little lego set
little life
on that note i gotta go i'm just gonna
say congrats on the movie and i
definitely don't think people are going
to see the third act coming
thank you